[Music]
so I
Intel officer and it's been with my time
out of Fort Benning and I chose Stanford
one for a couple reasons one I was a
West Coast er I grew up in Oregon
originally and I'm married and so we
thought long term wanted to be on the
west coast and so that kind of dropped
out some of the East Coast schools from
what we're really seriously considering
some of my geographical preference and
then the the two winners outside that
for me were kind of entrepreneurial
focus and I don't just mean tech VC
entrepreneurship I when I think about
entrepreneurship I think about in a wide
sense of I got I get the sense from
Stanford that we have one of the more
people go from the Stanford MBA into a
wider degree of things post MBA than
from other schools that I looked at so I
didn't know exactly what I wanted to do
so I got excited about having a school
that would allow me to look at seriously
look at anything from government work to
nonprofits to entrepreneurship of all
kinds to standard consulting finance etc
and then culture fit I'm a kind of a
West Coast casual guy I didn't want to
go to a business school that wanted me
to wear a tie or suit and I like the
kind of first-name basis everyone's here
to help each other not competing to rank
things like that like I wanted to that
was kind of my style that's how the
school matched that well so my name is
nicko I was in the Navy a submarine
officer and I chose Stanford for several
reasons as well the last five years I
was in New England never lived on the
west coast so I definitely was
interested in a new change of pace I
also felt that what was unique to
Stanford is that I would be outside my
comfort zone and that I I think
everything from the classroom setting to
the club's to events like small group
dinners there are opportunities littered
throughout the day where you can really
get to know your classroom are your
classmates especially with the class
size about a 417 like you really do get
to know of all your classmates so that's
something that really resonated within
me and
it was also like soidiers said very
interested in the entrepreneurial aspect
and I feel that Stanford lives and
breathes the entrepreneurial spirit so
there are anything you can think of I
truly believe you could kind of make a
reality here I'm Catherine I was a
captain in rank or a supply officer but
most of my time in Okinawa and I shall
Stanford kind of for similar reasons to
what Nikko said I wanted to get outside
of my comfort zone I was born and raised
on the East Coast I went to undergrad in
Boston
and never lived on the west coast before
so wanted to kind of try something new
in new culture also the Entrepreneurship
aspect was really outside of my comfort
zone as well there's a lot of people
here that are willing to take risks on a
big idea that they have and I thought
it's just really exciting atmosphere to
be around and finally and this was a
sense that I kind of had before I got to
Stanford but it's really been hammered
home since being here is it really truly
is a collaborative culture as well
people are genuinely rooting for each
other to succeed and really eager to
help out their classmates in whatever
way they can in achieving their goals so
I'm really glad that I came here and I
think I made a right way for me my
name's Ryan
Bowles I was an f-18 pilot in the Marine
Corps and for me I think the GSB when I
looked at a lot of schools had very
unique opportunities that I wouldn't be
able to find elsewhere and one thing
that kind of stood out was that the
program in the institution really
focused on developing students beyond
the classroom and trying to you know
help you like fully develop as a person
and one thing that stood out to me was a
quote that when people graduate from
here they when they walk across the
stage they feel just more comfortable in
their own skin which is a very
qualitative type measure but I thought
was very important and a crucial element
to be able to make this transition and
enter into a completely new
new workplace one question that came up
earlier or for the group and one that I
want to pose here is can you talk a
little bit about what the transition was
like from being in service to being a
student yeah so I have I'm uh I'm
starting but I'm also probably a little
different than most people on this call
which is I actually separated from the
army and then had about 18 months of
work in the civilian world before I came
to the GSB so that is possible for those
who are kind of feel like veterans being
a better and her being on active duty or
are in the reserves now was you know one
career ago or a couple years ago there
are those of us who do that I I spent
after doing my time in the Army I was
spend a little time kinda in this
startup an early investing world in in
Seattle and then applied from there down
and came and came down to the GSB so
that's a non-traditional track but you
can't separate and then apply and still
kind of leverage your what you learned
and your experience to the veteran
within the application and then once
you're at school
cool anybody else on the transition I
could speak on the other end of Sawyer I
I went on I separated went on terminal
in July and then came to Stanford in
September so it was a fairly quick
turnaround for me but I would say just
based off the the programming that's
available to all incoming MBA ones that
it was a very good structured format of
getting into the groove of things
getting to know your classmates and so
it really wasn't a big time demand or a
time sink for me to kind of like
transition other than moving out here so
I thought the Stanford set it up pretty
well for not just military but for
everyone to come together and kind of
get to know each other and get started
cool so yeah I'm actually going to use
this as a transition to our Q&A box so
for our attendees this is the time to
start asking some questions about the
experience again from the experts just
wanted to let people know about my
appreciation for the vets club and
everybody on this panel today's event is
really supported by the energy of our
vets Club and this came about because of
their advocacy and like support for
future veterans so much respect so much
appreciation to them for helping launch
this this event so the question that
Taylor's off of your response Neko is
how does this civil of civilian military
dynamic on campus how does that shape up
so you mentioned a little bit about that
transition in Stanford kind of using
that a little bit but how does that play
out on the ground like do people tend to
stick with people from similar
industries or is there like a bridge and
what does that look like yes and I saw
one of the examples was leadership labs
for those that are not familiar
leadership labs is a core course that
you take in your first quarter here and
that's where you get to be an
experimental setting gets you go through
roleplay scenarios and at least for me I
could experience that it really
resonated with me because the scenarios
that played out I felt like I had least
seen in some aspect previously due to my
military experience and for those
reasons I felt that I was a huge benefit
to my team being able to share those
experiences with them I will say that
compared to maybe what other schools are
the veterans club is not that large so
it's kind of in that sense it is what
you can make of it so there they're
going to be people that may not
necessarily know that much about the
military so the onus is a little bit on
you to kind of help them understand and
it's an extremely great conversation
starter talking about your experiences
because everyone here is very receptive
and varying curious to learn more about
you so it's it's a very good opportunity
to kind of share those experiences and
then there are instances like in
leadership labs where you can really
show the leadership experience just that
you gained in the military I would agree
with what Nikko said everyone here is
really open to learning about their
classmates different experiences and the
vesicle bit self isn't really an insular
isolated Club and the community it's one
that is constantly reaching out to our
peers and our classmates to share our
experiences see what questions that they
have the culture on campus is so
collaborative that there's you really
naturally bridge that gap and get to
know each other
they'll get to know you as people to not
just as the veteran in the class but
like you're a more three-dimensional
human being than just that so they'll
really want to know about your
experiences in military but also just
want to get to know you as a person as
well alright so speaking about
experiences um can you tell us a little
bit about something unexpected that you
experienced either during the admissions
process or while at the GSB
I think I don't mean to be like
dismissive of this but I think the most
surprising thing was getting accepted
and I say that because I think there are
there are a lot of people that probably
don't apply to the school because
acceptance rate is low anecdotally like
I am probably below the average for most
of the numbers that you see on the
website but I'm still sitting in in this
program and I think that's because
Stanford looks a lot at the entire
person and I think the essays are you
know something really you can use the
standout amongst your peer group and I'd
say like if you if you're interested in
the school and you're interested in this
program the cost is literally just the
time it takes for you to fill out the
application and I think the application
to this program is very unique and that
there's really no opportunity cost
because it's a massive reflection
exercise and I think that's just like a
value add and a benefit to anybody
that's that's applying to these programs
so like really think about why they want
to do it what they hope to get out of it
which I would submit is an a really
important thing to know when you walk
onto campus and in the fall to any
program you you enter because things
happen very quickly and if you have even
just general guidelines for where you're
looking to you know move it will be very
beneficial and I think you'll extract
more value out of the program than if
you try and go you know in a million
different directions at once cool so you
you mentioned a little bit about the
acceptance on that admission process
there is a question here that's
addressed towards Sawyer and I think you
indicated that you're gonna answer it
live so I think this could be a great
chance to and open it up to also other
panelists if you have thoughts on this
so Sawyer earlier mentioned that he had
not deciding exactly what he was going
to
laughter is getting his MBA like how did
you approach that and how did you share
that especially knowing that some some
other folks are in the same boat now
that you were in then yeah actually
going back to answer one of the
surprising things for me the first thing
that came to mind is when I got the call
that I was admitted for the admissions
officer who called me so there that she
was excited for my wife and I to be here
and named my wife by name and I thought
like I don't know if I put my wife's
name in any part of the application and
a part I was like oh you know how much
research do they do or something but on
the other hand it really felt like they
had they had looked at my application
and got excited about me as a person and
the you know the family I was bringing
and so that to me it was like kind of a
strong signal okay it wasn't just like I
checked the GMAT box checked like
recommendation box like they knew who
they were getting and they were excited
so that was pretty compelling for me on
the application yeah I didn't know what
I wanted to do I didn't know what I
wanted to do all last year either so a
lot of and a lot of people come in with
that perspective I think and whether
they admit it or not as Ryan said it's a
lot of self-reflection and figuring out
what's next so my recommendation is how
I articulated it in in the essays and
the application was here are the things
I care most about and and these are
parts of my past that have made that
clear to me and I want to spend more
time solving this general areas problems
I want to invest in small communities I
want to develop leaders I want to help
those who come from rural areas like I
do I don't know how to do that yet but I
know that because of these experiences
business is a way for me to do that and
I want to spend two years at the MBA
program getting the skills and
reflecting on how to do that better and
that was kind of how I wrote it and I
was concerned that it was a little vague
I wasn't saying I want to be a
consultant in two years and then do this
I wasn't being specific but it was true
and I think the I hope that the truth of
I don't know exactly what this looks
like but I know what I care
most about and I know stamp it will help
me guilt we get there I think that that
came through I started encourage people
not to try to write something they think
the addcom wants to hear I think that
does not hold the power of being true
even if it's a little unsure yes I
second that just speak to what's
meaningful for you and this also kind of
addresses one of the questions from
earlier today I was like how much
exploration happens during business
school so kind of nice to see how this
is gone a little full circle here okay
so there is a question here of about the
experience so we're gonna shift gears
just a little bit here um so Katherine
and Nico this is a question from Dani in
your intros you mentioned coming to the
GSB to push your comfort zone and to
push yourself out of your comfort zone
can you tell us maybe is there like an
anecdote or story that encapsulate it's
like a moment where that's happened
I think one of the things that they do
at Stanford is consistently try and set
up spaces where people can make
themselves vulnerable and really share
stories about their past or like things
that make them insecure that was a very
unfamiliar thing to me and I think still
is kind of something that makes me
uncomfortable making myself like so
vulnerable and open to people that some
people I might know some people I might
might not don't even know that well yet
one of the things that they do every
week at Stanford has had something
called talk where people can just talk
for 45 minutes about a story that's
meaningful to them and so far I haven't
done one yet
but I plan on doing one next year and
they've all been really powerful stories
the stories that the classmates have
shared so far and I'm excited for the
chance to maybe share my story as well
yes I was second everything that that
Catherine said there are things that are
there that are sprinkled throughout
one's day at Stanford that can really
give you the opportunity to come outside
your comfort zone I distinctly remember
the very first class of managing groups
and teams is when the teacher told us or
the professor told us all right
introduce yourself to your the person
sitting next to you and don't say hi
don't say how are you but delve right
into the question about tell me the
story behind your name and I was just
taken back a little bit because I'm
thinking when I meet people or introduce
or get to know someone that maybe that's
not a conversation that comes up at all
but there are instances like that one
day that I experienced where they kind
of have like this way of being able to
kind of deep deep quickly and establish
that that trust in that community and
and like Kathryn said there's the
opportunity where you have classmates
that can talk that give a talk for 40
minutes and some of them are that
they're really deep and personal and
these are like kana opportunities that
you're seeing yourself in another
setting I don't know if I would have
been able to
learn that much about somebody else and
so I'm grateful that there is these
opportunities to kind of step outside
the comfort zone at Stanford so I don't
I think another thing that helps you is
like a lot of MBA programs there's this
policy of grayed non-disclosure as well
so if you're looking to get out of your
comfort zone in a more academic
practical sense it's pretty low risk to
take courses that really challenge you a
lot because even if you even if it is
pushing kind of yourself away possible
you've ever done before and you don't
get the best grade or the grade you are
hoping for it it doesn't really matter
the course program is designed for you
to be able to try those new things and
really push yourself nice and so
question here we talked a little bit
about the transition the application
process transition to the GSB a little
bit about the experience and now like
already so I'm going to think of the
next steps can you can you guys talk a
little bit about like the the job hunt
process like end of the recruiting
process what's that like especially like
if you happen to be considered and
you're not sure what you want to do just
yeah like what does that like yeah I can
start us off here I so there's a
specific question here from Ryan about
recruiting process how quickly does it
start upon arrival at the GSB and how do
you engage with that if you still are
unsure so for me I was unsure I mean I
actually started kind of working
backwards I thought about things I
didn't want to do and I as I went to
some of the recruiting events and things
that happen
I became clear I didn't really want to
consulting I didn't want to do some the
traditional finance stuff I didn't some
of the big tech companies weren't
appealing to me so that I just kinda
started limiting I went from like what
what's all possible to then marking
things off the list and and I didn't I
didn't have an internship you know fully
locked in till probably Spring Quarter
and that was fine there's a lot of
pressure here in the fall if you're
doing traditional recruiting
and maybe every MBA to like get that
locked in early but many many many
people don't have internships or
certainly real clarity about their jobs
until a few months before summer and I
guess one thing it's a little bit
specific to the GSB is there's an
academic adjustment period in the fall
which basically prevents recruiters from
harassing you or or having events or
anything for like til Thanksgiving I
think will or it's eight weeks or six
weeks so all the first years are
basically on lockdown and I found
actually that that was that was great
for the first month or so it allowed me
just to like be here and meet people and
focus on school and the move and things
like that
but then I actually started to kind of
get an ANSI like I want to go explore
now it didn't so but I thought it was a
nice time because then you couldn't I
couldn't expect myself to also be doing
the job hunting yet because technically
it was it was like against school policy
and I wasn't getting emails or getting
recruiter things or having events every
night I feel like I should be that it
was all just it was all kind of quiet I
can maybe add some points as well
definitely second the academic
adjustment period that's where I
mentioned I found that to be pretty
helpful to allow me to like focus on one
one area at a time I think in the
veteran community this might echo or was
a bit of like a phased approach for me
an academic just appear was kind of like
a line where I was shifting my focus
from academics until that ended and then
trying to blend in some recruitment
along with academics one thing that I
did before coming to school was explore
some of the like I'm a more traditional
side some companies and firms will have
things that you can either attend over
the summer so if you have the
opportunity that take terminal leave or
vacation or stop working with a little
bit of space before you start school I
think that was very helpful to do like
formal and
in formal searching so I did some
research on the Internet I spoke with
people in industries and kind of started
to hone the questions that I wanted to
ask people so I could really listen to
their answers and see what resonated
with me and what I wanted to focus on I
ended up focusing on consulting I went
through a fairly large cycle including
in an internship at Goldman that kind of
directed me away from some of those some
other industries as well as looking at
stuff in in tech and I thought that that
the recruitment process when that like
probably more traditional process
started it is pretty fast so if you do
think that that's what you want to go
down or your research and reflection
over the summer starts putting you on
that path it's good do a little bit of
the pre-work before that kicks off
because when academic adjustment period
ends you're kind of like in a massive
sprint until from it was like October
through January until final round
interviews were complete how has how
didn't folks like facilitate like
learning about job opportunities or
pivots did you use the Career Management
Center did you network through events on
campus through classmates or alumni like
what were some of the different ways
that you've engaged with a recruiting
process we attended a lot of events that
were hosted on campus but it
I also talked a lot to my classmates
because your classmates are going to
have worked in all of these industries
that you're looking at most likely
including you'll probably have
classmates that have founded their own
companies in the past and have
experienced entrepreneurship as well so
really almost anything that you might be
interested in you can probably find a
peer that has done something like that
and would be more than happy to sit down
over coffee or take a walk and have a
chat about it I did a lot of some
there's a lot of like brown bag lunches
where companies will come and talk about
themselves or like their industry and
they're usually there there was some
business cards cuz they want an intern
or two and they'll literally be every
lunch like every every day of the week
at lunch there'll be multiple brown bag
lunches and usually get free food and
you twist in the company if you're
interested you know shake their hands
afterwards and talk to him follow-up
email so I did a lot of that I also
found I did a lot there was I held
myself accountable to like a couple
alumni reach out per week I think for
the first two quarters I was here and I
found that particularly effective
especially in the veteran community
because it's a really small community so
there is one veteran who graduated from
here probably 10 years ago I've never
met he was he was in the Navy I was in
the army and he has no connection to me
other than we he went to the GSB ten
years ago and now works as an investor
in Texas for a big Silicon Valley
entrepreneur kind of guy and not only
did it take my first call but then he
suggested a time to follow up next week
and had another 45 minute call and I was
out of questions I didn't even know what
to talk about anymore but he was just so
happy to chat that and that kind of
Daisy changed on - oh you're in this
here I mean you got to talk to this guy
or this gal and so I found the veterans
alums to be super helpful I'm small but
really impactful cool and we're getting
close oh this pad this section so if we
can close that I have one question that
actually encapsulate sac Uppal of
different things folks have been asking
in the Q&A box if you could share
something like a piece of advice either
with applicant you or like MBA one year
you when you were just starting what
would that advice be yeah for MBA one me
I would say that if you haven't heard
already there there is this notion of
the FOMO or fear of missing out there
are going to be a lot of events going on
on campus
you got your classwork you got these
career events you have clubs and then
you have just the natural tendency
of classmates just wanted to hang out
grab a drink or go for a walk or whatnot
and it can very easily overwhelm you
very quickly and the thing is it's just
treated like you've treated anything
else in the past it's something that you
know it's okay to say no to certain
events it's okay to take certain time
there's not this notion that everyone's
doing something at any given time like
it is okay to like you know this is your
journey so you know make sure you take
time to to do what you want to do and if
you need some time off you know to make
sure you do that it in make this
experience how you want this experience
to be
[Music]